-You know our first guest
tonight from his work
on shows like "Community"
and "The Soup."
He stars in the new film
"Happily,"
which premieres
in theaters, on digital,
and on demand on March 19th.
Let's take a look.
-We are prepared to take ful
responsibility for our mishap.
-Mishap?
-Yes.
-I think we're going to need
some kind of
an explanation here.
-You see, every few years we
encounter someone with a defect,
but two people
with a malfunction,
that,
that is what we call a rarity.
-Please welcome back to the show
Joel McHale, everybody.
Oh. Oh, nice!
-Thank you!
-Nice, thank you!
-Thank you.
-This is so --
-Thank you, Fred.
Great to see you, Fred.
Thank you.
-This is so refreshing.
-Hey! So...
[ Laughs ]
-Whoo-hoo!
-Whoo!
-Here you go,
a little handshake.
There you go. Hi, buddy.
-Nice to see you.
-I mean, that --
-Until you did it, I didn'
realize how much I missed it
-Ah. Whoo!
Ah, "Late Night" so great.
Seth, you look incredible.
-Thank you.
-Congrats on the kids.
It's just -- Thank you!
-That's it?
-Thank you so much.
-He's out.
-Yes, thank you, alright.
Thanks.
-You know, our East Coast
viewers are not gonna celebrat
the fact that you're
wearing shorts right now.
I think that's real show-off-y
and a little mean.
-Well, look, here
in Southern California,
it's, you know,
almost late March, my friend
I mean, it's mid-March.
But still, it is -- whew! --
time to break out.
I mean, we use umbrellas
to keep --
I have to --
to keep from sunburning.
-Wow. Life is pretty --
-Sorry.
-Life is pretty good for you
And, Joel, I'm not surprised
I know you to be
a hardworking guy.
A lot of people, well,
it was a tough year.
They used to it to maybe
celebrate inactivity.
That has never been
the Joel McHale way.
-Oh, no.
I am --
I feel like someone's gonna take
all my money
away from me all the time.
I'm constantly running,
like that joke you told
about the LGBTQ person
running across Mississippi
-Right.
-I am an obsessive-compulsiv
workaholic.
I feel like you're right there
when you yelled at Scollin
and which now I'm going to use
if ever a joke is a little -
every time, I'm just gonna go,
"Scollins?
What the hell?"
It doesn't grammatically -
What? Dick's size?
It doesn't --
-Yeah.
-I thought it worked great
-And, by the way, if you eve
tell a bad joke,
don't feel bad blaming Scollins,
'cause he would have written it.
[ Laughter ]
-He'd be like --
But then do you self-loathe?
Because it came out
of your mouth.
You're like, "Well, I give him
one, I guess. But here we go."
-Oh, no, I don't
self-loathe at all.
All my loathing is reserve
for Scollins.
[ Laughter ]
-Scollins sounds like
a disorder of the skin.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah. Yeah.
-Like someone who wears a pair
of underwear for too long
and then like, "Ah, [bleep],
I got Scollins."
-Well, it's interesting.
[ Laughter ]
So, we get swabbed every day
coming to work.
And I keep, you know,
obviously God bless,
I keep testing negative
for coronavirus.
But I do -- I did test positiv
for Scollins.
-Oh, no!
-Yeah.
Got it bad.
-Seth, do not scratch it.
That will make it worse, okay?
[ Laughter ]
-I know.
-It spreads it.
I can see you moving
around a bit.
Like, "Ugh, my Scollins!"
-Yeah.
I don't know what else
to do about it.
Hey, was this true
of you forever,
that you've always been
a workaholic,
even before you found
your way into showbiz?
-Oh, yeah.
I have a real problem.
I would do --
I'm one of those people
that had like 12 jobs.
I think that's why I never say
no to anything.
And because -- so, I was -
I had a paper route.
Literally, I trimmed trees
I had an espresso cart.
I was in the mob.
[ Laughter ]
I sold heroin.
I lost my virginity
to Charlie Sheen.
That was also a job.
[ Laughter ]
So, yeah, a lot.
I did everything.
And I know -- because you're
the same type of person,
because you're like 41 or 40.
know you're barely in your 40s
-47!
47.
-And you have that hair?
Your hair is perfect, and yo
didn't even have to pay for it
the way that I did mine.
Damn it!
-Yours looks wonderful.
It was --
To quote Charlie Sheen,
it was worth every penny.
-See? This is --
I'm a big "Peaky Blinders" fan
-It is very "Peaky Blinders.
Hey, you tried to get a little
scratch on the side
playing a little celebrity
"Wheel of Fortune."
-Oh, yeah.
-We only have one photo,
but obviously, based on this
you were doing pretty well
[ Laughter ]
-Okay. Okay.
Paul Reubens
doesn't have anything.
-Well, Paul Reubens, he's go
that Pee-wee money.
He doesn't need anything.
-Yes.
He's very rich.
And he's very --
Both Nicole and -- So, he won,
but this is how
stupid celebrities
are on "Wheel of Fortune,"
is that there is a game wher
they start revealing a puzzle,
and they just start
showing letters,
and then you guess it
as it's being revealed.
All the letters appeared,
and none of us were fast enoug
to even say it.
Even though it was all
right there.
It was just reading a sentence
I totally [bleep]
Scollinsed it, and --
[ Laughter ]
Then they stopped the show
They were like,
"This never happens."
"We can't -- We have to reload
an entire new puzzle
according to
the game show police."
-Yeah.
-But I couldn't believe
I was there because --
Oh, go ahead.
Sorry.
-The only thing I'd say,
you would think
if you had three actors,
the one thing they would
be able to do is read lines.
-You'd think.
[ Laughter ]
But I'm dyslexic,
so I can't read as it is.
That's why I went into acting.
Yeah. Oh, I guess Nicole -
Did she win?
-Look at how much fun
you guys are having.
That's the least happy I've ever
seen Paul Reubens, by the way.
-Yeah, I was so pissed tha
I broke Nicole's leg.
[ Laughter ]
-Wait. That happened the day of?
-Yeah.
I was just so mad.
Oh, maybe --
This is how dumb I am.
I think she --
I don't know who won.
I just kept asking Pat Sajak
when the last time
he flew commercial was.
[ Laughter ]
And to which he was like
"Can't remember, Joel."
[ Laughter ]
And then they turned him off
He's very nice.
He was like,
"We're just playing Hangman.
And I was like,
"You made all the money
in Hollywood playing Hangman."
He's like, "Well, that is true
that is true."
[ Laughter ]
-Hey, this movie is --
I thought that was
a very good clip,
because this movie,
while very funny, is very dark
and has some turns
you don't see coming.
Did you enjoy making it?
-Oh, I loved it.
I made sure I knew my lines.
I didn't Scollins
a single thing.
[ Laughter ]
And I was just -- No.
Look, I got to work
with Kerry Bishé,
who is one of the best actor
I've ever worked with.
And Stephen Root, who is -
You know Stephen.
He's working with your frien
Bill Hader there on "Barry,"
one of the best shows
on television.
And the movie's premise
was so different.
It's a couple that's been
married for 14 years,
and they have sex
three times a day,
and their friends
hate them for it,
and then it gets really
different and "Twilight Zone-y."
So I said sign me up for that.
That sounds like the next
"Endgame."
So I'm in.
-Well, I mean this sincerely
I think one of the hardest
things for a movie
to do these days
is to go somewhere
where you did not see it going
and it is really mission
accomplished.
It's a great cast.
It's super fun to see you in it.
-I just mimicked
your performance
from "New Year's Eve."
-Thank you.
-It was -- You had so much sex
in that, that I was like,
"That's how you do it."
-Yeah. I actually --
they cut out most of
my sex stuff in the end.
But in the extended version --
-Oh, did you have Scollins then?
-I did.
[ Laughter ]
They thought they could
digitize it out,
but then in the end, they were
like -- it was pretty --
It was just --
-No.
They don't have
that technology yet.
-Thank you so much
for being here.
Congrats on the movie.
It's always a delight
to talk to you,
and I hope to see you soon
-Seth, you're the smartest
funniest person on television,
and it really pisses me off.
[ Laughter ]